FIFA and cattle have long promised that  alcohol would be served in such States  on Match days but today they only 36  hours before the tournament kicks off  they've reversed that decision FIFA  confirmed it was a statement  why we know that the Qatari authorities  have pressured FIFA to keep alcohol  branding to a minimum and to be honest  there are very few overt signs of  alcohol advertisements around the city  most of the fans we've spoken to some of  them from England Argentina Mexico the  Netherlands they're not too bothered by  it they are here to watch the football  and it is true that this is the first  World Cup to be held in the Muslim  country and there will be a lot of fans  coming from around the Middle East and  many more I expect  employment  football fans if they do want to drink  though it's not an outright ban they  will be able to buy alcohol  and Hotel Bars and major fan zones set  up  [Music]